(slogans des manifestants)
scandent ces manifestants
à Téhéran. Ils crient
"Masha Amini", un nom devenu,
depuis trois jours, le cri de
ralliement des Ira
réclament plus de liberté.
La jeune femme de 22 ans est
décédée en prison, vendredi,
quelques jours après avoir
été arrêtée, à Téhéran, sous
prétexte qu'elle ne portait pas
"Je m'oppose vigoureusement à
ces méthodes, dit cet ét,,,,
on ne peut pas imposer
une pratique culturelle
par la force".
Les circonstances de la mort
sont suspectes. Des groupes
de défense des droits en Iran
affirment que Masha
a probablement été battu
ce qui nient toujours
les autorités iraniennes.
"Cette femme n'a pas été battues
de frapper des inculpés,
les agents n'ont pas de bâton."
Mais les Iraniens ne semble pas
croire ce démenti, sans doute
dans les prisons du pays.
(slogans des manifestants)
"Je tuerais l'assassin dequququs
contre les femmes en Iran.
(cris de détresse)
Des manifestatio e e e eu lieu
un peu partout au pays.
Des hommes et des femmes de tous
âges, de prprprprprprprprprprprn
du régime.
ELAHEHOHOHOHOUF
- Ça a monté une vague
Aujourd'hui, j'ai vraiment la
chair de poule de vo d d d dans
plus d'une centaine de villes en
le régime des Ayattolah pendant
10 ans avant de fuir l'Iran,
quand son mari a été torturé
en prison. La mort de Masha
l'a boulversée.
- J'ai pensé que ça aurait pu
(sanglots)
Pendant la révolution, moi aussi
avec mes E E E E E E E E E E E ,
c'est depuis 1979 que les femmes
se b. . . . Trois semaines après
la révolution, on s'est battues
le 8 mars contre le régime
mimimimique. Et depuis,onononons
ont continué avec beaucoup
isisisisère, des arrestations,
des emprisonnements.
(slogansananananifestants)
- La force des manifesmomomomomt
de la jeune Masha, aussi
horrible soit-elle,
provoquer les changements
réclamés par de plus en plus
d'Iraniens.
- Si sa mort peut apporter
une ouverture de la société
en Iran, ça va être...
En tout cas, on paie la liberté
très cher, vous le savez,
dans ce pays-là.
Radio-Canada, Montréal